foreign
so I did my first flip
in
1983. the year before I was born so that
would be
30 years ago right or 40 years ago 40 40
years 40 years ago 40 years ago yeah the
first flip I did
I was so stupid
that I thought that everything that was
a foreclosure
was a good buy
that if it said foreclosure that it must
be cheap I equated foreclosure with
cheap which sometimes is true I think
most people do but I bought a HUD repo
they used to put them in the newspaper
and you would bid on them FHA Reef FHA
foreclosures HUD repo out of the news
you had a newspaper as a bid process I
turned in the bid I talked a banker into
financing 100 of it because I had a real
estate degree I was a real estate guy I
knew all about real estate and I was 23
years old so I was a freaking genius
okay
and so I bought this house
I knew everything about the house before
I bought it I'd gone through it with a
fine tooth comb okay the um
in those days they used uh we we used uh
copper pipes for the water supply
and the cut the house had been sitting
empty and so the copper pipes had Frozen
and split and so it was pretty much a
sprinkler system
underneath uh and you had to go through
and redo the copper pipes and I knew how
to do that because I'd done Renovations
work in high school working for my dad
in the real estate business so I crawled
around on my little back under there
with a little torch and fixed all of the
spliced all these pipes fixed all the
pipes uh put new carpet in it went in on
the weekends and Sharon and I repainted
it okay and I kept all of my receipts
for what I spent and paid myself zero
labor
how stupid I was and we put the house on
the market
and it sold in five weeks so I'm a huge
success
net net net net when I got done
I added up what we had in it what we
paid for the closing costs what we paid
on the closing cost on the resale
what actual after every dollar is
recorded what actual net profit did I
make
842 dollars you're an overnight success
I'm now on game on can't nobody tell you
obviously good at this
which means that I probably paid myself
what a dollar an hour labor
well you know I didn't get paid for the
labor the 842 was with this free labor I
had I had slave labor me yeah you and my
wife and my wife yeah so we're in there
so that was job one okay the next one I
will I bought and I thought well I'm not
buying any houses in bad neighborhoods
because I don't know anything about all
that stuff I'll get in trouble but this
guy called me up and he had a house and
he sold it to me for seven thousand
dollars
and I ran the in what I thought was the
estimate and I had three contractors
look at it and give us bids and uh the
first contractor wanted a fifteen
hundred dollar deposit up front
never saw him again right
went to his trailer and knocked on the
door in the trailer park trying to get
my fifteen I wonder what I didn't get
shot by the way he had already left and
gone to Kalamazoo or wherever it is
contractors go when they take your
fifteen hundred dollars because you're
an idiot and you give it to them up
front yeah and so then I started
on the second contractor the third
contractor the fourth contractor and uh
when I finished with that property it I
had already done a whole bunch of other
deals by then uh like uh 60 or 80 more
deals oh my gosh by the time I finish
that property I ended up only losing
fourteen thousand dollars on a house I
paid seven thousand for four and a half
years later oh my gosh this is how dumb
I am so if that wait if that that's
another house had been your first house
I would have been out of business yeah I
would have been Nate yeah you would have
been like I'm never doing this my wife
would have been going yeah
instead I managed to delay the pain on
that one meanwhile doing a whole bunch
of others and I made a lot of money yeah
I made a lot of money I ended up in my
life I have owned over 2 000 pieces of
real estate I flipped real estate as my
job for four years by I was using 90 day
notes to fix them and flip them I made
and I started buying property at 70
cents on the dollar minus repairs
wow so a hundred thousand dollar
property I buy it for 70 minus the
repairs that was the formula and that
means I bought a lot of foreclosures a
lot of Estates I did some historic
rehabs we've done a bazillion deals I
can walk around Nashville I did that
house that house that house that house
30 40 years later I want to take that
tour and uh yeah you don't want to be in
that neighborhood probably but um okay
some of those neighborhoods are now
gentrified but um gotcha they've come
back a long way from seven thousand
dollars now it's 260 to live on that
street and it's a great property not
really still in Dodge City the shoot up
down the street it's Dodge City I don't
care whether it's gentrified or not so
anyway the uh you're killing me here but
yeah so this is this is my real estate
career so when I get aggravated at the
idiots on Tic Tac it's because I was one
of them yeah okay I was doing the exact
same stuff and I can smell
neophyte
beginner a mile away yeah because I was
I was I was 23 I was going to get rich
in real estate I made 842 dollars minus
the cost of my labor I lost 14 000 and
then I went on to make money and make
money and I started figuring it out that
I had to you know I had to I had to I
had to be tough with contractors I had
to get with good ones and and I had to
have be tough on schedules you had to be
finished and then you put the house on
the market aggressively and you flip it
you don't keep it ever and uh you know
not like her we're not in the rental
business and then then I ended up buying
a bunch of property I buy packages of
houses about 10 or 20 at once and they
were rental portfolio and I lost every
bit of that when I went bankrupt in uh
in
1988 five years later I have now owned
had four million dollars worth of real
estate when we went in that's a fast one
in a bankruptcy that's a whirlwind day
it was I worked all the time and I was
really really good at doing deals but
I'm saying to go for from Zero to Hero
or hero to zero and back Zero to Hero to
zero that's a PhD in d u m b is what
that is yeah and so but I got a lifetime
of learning there and it led me to have
a bullcrap meter that is very sensitive
to real estate people and uh so you know
when you guys are talking about right
now because real estate's real hot right
right it's a popular fad topic again
everybody wants to do a real estate deal
everybody wants to do a flip everybody
wants to own a real estate and your
renters will pay your rent rentals will
pay the payment you don't worry about it
it says people who've never had renters
that's a dumb butt statement okay let me
tell you let me teach you some words
chapter 13. bankruptcy for I will pay
you when by God I want to
okay and let me tell you what you can do
with a tenant who's in a bankruptcy
nothing wow you have a stay on you which
is an injunction a federal court has
looked at you like a dog and said stay
and as a creditor if you even call your
tenant you can be held inconvenient of
Court wow you cannot talk to them you
cannot do anything except everything
they wish as far as repairs while they
pay zero rent because you stay dog stay
yeah you learn this when you've had a
couple of them so when renters are
always they're going to pay the payment
and it's a free house and I'm I you know
I have a jet airplane and you're just an
idiot you're just an idiot on Tick Tock
that's what you are it's unbelievable
well here so real real estate is great
but you there's a people factor with the
contractors there's a people factor with
the renters there's a people Factor when
I overestimate how what the uh how how
much money I'm gonna make I
underestimate the contractor the time
it's going to take to run it I I I think
it's going to sell faster than it is
because I'm always a glass half full guy
and right before that's when you get
your freaking nose bloodied slow down
people pay cash for the stuff and run it
like a business not like a get rich
quick scheme it's your only hope of
doing making money in real estate that
is not a poor man's game I think that's
the part that anybody can take away from
this is it would be one thing Dave I
feel like if you were sitting here going
I tried that really real estate thing
and this is what happens and it was just
like this negative story but then you go
on and figure out the best way to do
this the smarter way to do it the way
that actually works and that's what
you're teaching it's not like you're
saying stay away from Real Estate never
do it there's just a right and a wrong
way to do it I was 24 years old I had a
million dollar net worth in 1984 and I
made 250 000 that year that's 20 000
bucks a month in 1984. okay in 1988 my
taxable income was six thousand dollars
Wow all I did was sell property and
bankruptcy this is the Ramsay show